qui a dit qu'il fallait attendre les
beaux jours pour jardiner en ce début
novembre l'automne s'installe dans nos
jardins et cela ne rime pas forcément
avec ramassage des feuilles mortes
on peut s'en servir comme de terreau
dans les massifs c'est à dire les
soufflés dans les massifs et après
bêcher et donc les incorporés en terre
ça permet de créer un engrais vert
finalement voilà
et donc est donc de l'humus à terme et
donc de l'engrais pour vos plantes dans
les massifs je cuisine ou encore le
froid ne nuit pas aux plantes un végétal
ne réagit pas du tout comme un humain
c'est pas parce qu'il fait froid pour
nous que le végétal à froid
lui au contraire c'est vraiment l'époque
où il va émettre ses racines voilà donc
il a besoin de cette période de dormance
autre surprise de tonnes certaines
plantes sont encore en fleurs on prend
son mal en patience c'est quand même
dommage de se séparer de deux de
floraison actuellement l on va les
laisser tranquilles enfin le mois de
novembre
c'est aussi la période de plantation de
certains arbres fruitiers comme les
pommiers
mais attention pour les faire fructifier
l'emplacement est important on va
rechercher un minimum de soleil quand
même pour que la fructification se fasse
se fasse bien et surtout que le bourgeon
au printemps quand il est clos soit au
maximum au soleil pour pour essayer
d'animer les toutes petites gelé ce
qu'il ya important c'est de forcément de
bien orienter son son sujet et bien sûr
de regarder que le col et c'est à dire
la base de la plante soit au niveau du
sol a ajouté une dose d'engrais naturel
et il n'y a plus qu'à attendre le
printemps pour la floraison